that's so important and that's not
something I think you get just from you
know surfing the internet right of
course quickly know seen a couple of
YouTube videos by someone that's not
necessarily reliable that's a problem
right
how much misinformation has been spread
through YouTube more more than good
information Pro hopefully yeah I mean we
could put on some fake lab coats right
now and just make some nonsense video
exactly and see I've had the problem too
in my business you know what I'm talking
about
is that they say you can't please
everyone all the time but it seems like
in some cases in my career in this field
I've been able to displease everyone
because I'll come out with positions
sometimes sorry I'm losing my headset
I'll come out with positions sometimes
where I'm not pleasing my academic
colleagues but I'm not extreme enough
for the should we say other sides you
know so it's I'm like caught in the
middle cuz I'm going by the evidence I
actually have and it's not jiving with
so speak the same oil hot brigade yeah
so well how is that received by the
people that mean there are those ancient
aliens type folks that really want
everything they want everything to be
ancient aliens and I've been accused of
how could I not accept this or that you
know me too
yeah if they're nasty soon they'll even
tell me well this supports what
everything you've been saying I don't
care if it supports everything I've been
saying it's not real it's not real if
the evidence isn't there it's not you
know it is fascinating that they do dig
up these ancient structures and the
Machu Picchu there's different places
where like wow these construction
methods are really pretty impressive in
what was going on back then but they
always want to tie it to aliens they
always want to tie it to aliens which i
think is a I hate to use this term but
sort of a cop-out yeah it's a business
well that's where it gets down to why
this is business people want to sell
their books they want to sell their
conferences they want to sell their DVDs
they want to sell their YouTube videos
in some cases they want to sell for
money in some cases they want to sell
for
motion self-promotion they want to be
famous I told you I was accused of that
back yeah in early 90s oh oh I just
doing this place there won't be famous
no I'm not that type of person people
love those shows those UFO and ancient
alien type shows and they love those
conferences they go to those conferences
and they all just masturbate together
but they're all like yeah there's no
saying but I think it does feel a void
for some people and one thing I'm trying
to do is to fill that void with
something real right something important
something that has evidence to back it
up because there are a lot of the
questions there are a lot of mysteries
and I will admit I've been on the
ancient alien show but I've never
proposed ancient aliens I've never
supported that I've always been clear if
people actually listen to me but they
asked me to be on a number of other
academics have to do they go out of
context a little bit well yeah the
context is not slippery yes LaBrie but
the point is that there are real
mysteries to this yes they things that
we don't really understand that you and
I have been discussing about and there's
so many more we could discuss but those
are real and so many people that I know
that watch shows like that when I talk
to them and I'm talking academics who
would never admit that they watch it
they watch it because they find it
entertaining number one they don't quite
say this way but I think it fills a void
and it does raise issues that if they're
perceptive then they might become aware
of and realize that these are real
issues no ancient aliens or some other
easy answer is not the way to go but
they are real things that need to be
looked into
so even when I speak at a conference
like that there are so many very
intelligent people that are there
besides the other but you know there are
different types of people sure but I
know many people they'll have PhDs and
stuff and they'll go to it for a serve
between entertainment but also to get
exposed to things they're not going to
be exposed to by the stand
academic community you're not going to
get exposed to a lot of this these types
of questions if you just go to the
standard closed academic conferences